Speaker 1: Hey, Donald Trump was onto
something when he indirectly criticized
Florida Gov. Ron DeSantis for not admitting
that he's gotten his COVID booster. This is
a really interesting developing story. So here's
the back story Back in December, Trump brown noser
Maria Bartiromo asked Florida Gov. Ron DeSantis,
also known as Ron Death Santas, in some circles.
Have you gotten the booster? And DeSantis didn't
answer the question. OK, so let me set the stage
with this original clip from December gov.
Speaker 5: We're not even sure what fully
vaccinated means anymore. The other day, Dr.
Fauci said, You know, we could be that fully
vaccinated means three shots, which is two shots
for the vaccination and then one booster shot.
Have you gotten the booster?
Speaker 3:
So I've done whatever I did, the normal shot,
and you know that at the end of the day is
people's individual decisions about what
Speaker 1: they want to do.
I've done whatever I've done. Yes, right. And
what we are trying to ascertain is what is it
that you have done, but you didn't answer.
Speaker 3: But these boosters in terms now
Florida, we don't. We ban vaccine passports.
We won't let them fire even private businesses
over this because we don't think. Did you get the
Speaker 1: booster in Florida? We won't let them
fire you if you don't get the booster right.
But the question was, did you get the booster?
So Donald Trump, to his credit, to his credit,
as part of this building fight between Trump
and DeSantis, which is really it's an early
fight for the 2024 Republican nomination.
Don't be confused that it's anything else.
Donald Trump astutely pointed out that there are
these politicians who won't tell you if they got
the booster. This was Trump when interviewed by
OANN, and he's talking about Ron DeSantis here,
but he doesn't name him by name. It's something
Speaker 3: out there. But after now, so many
months of the vaccine being administered and
these side effects at Americans questions of it,
do you reconsider your push for it or what's your
view now on the vaccine in general? Well, I've
taken it. I've had the booster, many politicians.
I watched a couple of politicians be interviewed.
And one of the questions was, did you get the
booster because they had the vaccine and they,
oh, they're answering it. Like, in other words,
the answer is yes, but they don't want to say it
because they're gutless. They say it, whether you
had it or not, say. But the fact is that I think
the vaccine has saved tens of millions of people
throughout the world. I have had absolutely no
side effects. I've had it, like other people have
Speaker 1: said Trump, is we know he's referring
to Ron DeSantis, and Trump is increasingly
starting to attack DeSantis directly.
Roger Stone has started to attack Ron DeSantis.
DeSantis has started to back away from Trump and
say things like maybe shouldn't have followed
him quite as much on COVID leadership early in
the pandemic. Remember, there was no such
leadership, but doesn't really matter. Ron
DeSantis over the weekend was asked again very
directly Did you get your COVID booster? And
now he is straight up admitting he's not going
to say, why not going to say whether he got it?
Because it's going to be used against him?
Speaker 3: Governor, have you received your
COVID booster shot? So that's something that,
you know, I think people should just make their
own decisions on. I'm not going to, but
Speaker 1: the question was not whether
we know others should decide. We're asking you,
governor, what did you decide? And then he says
he's not going to he's not going to say,
Speaker 3: let that be be a weapon for
people to be able to use. I think it's a private
matter. We've worked hard to be able to protect
people so they don't lose their jobs on that.
Speaker 1: Now understand that DeSantis says
his position is if I understand it correctly, he
got vaccinated. He won't say if he got booster,
but he says he got vaccinated, he got vaccinated.
But they won't allow the mandates in Florida,
and they won't allow you to be fired
because you haven't been vaccinated. So
the coherent position would be I did get
boosted and I don't believe anyone should
be fired if they don't get boosted. That's a
completely coherent position. But DeSantis knows
that his Republican followers in Florida
are so weaponized and so uninformed
that if he just admits that he got the booster,
he will get people who are mad at him for that.
That's why, because there's no it wouldn't
become a weapon. If you say I've chosen
to get it and everybody should be able to
make the choice and no one should be fired.
That's that's a coherent position. It's not. We
don't have to agree with the with the position,
but it's coherent. It shouldn't make any of
his followers mad, but it will. And that's why
DeSantis isn't admitting that he got the booster.
Speaker 3: I have said publicly that, you know,
the FDA recommended it against boosters for
people in my age group when the CDC overrode that,
and I think that was based on politics. I
don't think that that was based on science.
Two of the top FDA people actually resigned in
protest. Many people didn't hear about that.
Speaker 1: Remember, the question
was, Did you get your booster?
Speaker 3: You know why? Well, because it
didn't fit the narrative. I can tell you
if you had a different president of a different
party, that would have been hair on fire stuff.
You know that people would have been able to do
so in Florida. They've been available for people.
People can make their own decisions on it.
But it's not been something that you know
that we've been telling people in my age
group, you know, to go out and do right.
Speaker 1: But again, that was not
the question. The question was simply,
did you get the booster and going very much out of
his way to avoid saying whether he did or didn't?
I think he probably did his. It would be crazy
not to, particularly given that Ron DeSantis,
his wife, is currently undergoing treatment for
breast cancer. It would be wholly irresponsible
for him not to get that third dose, given how
effective it is at. Venting serious illness
and and according to what Vincent Racaniello
told us last week, reducing the possibility that
you transmit the virus to others. So I think
he probably did get it, but understand how
weaponized the people around him are that he can't
even admit it. And Trump is right. He should. You
should just say it either got it or I didn't,
and deal with whatever the consequences are.